peu vous devenez ces amendes pour
présenter votre dernier film le gendarme
se marie laure ce gendarme de saint
tropez générant dur
il est donc le mariage c'est le dernier
épisode
non non non ça n'a peut-être prévu
encore un autre victime l'épisode mais
c'est l'histoire d'un gendarme qui est
un peu tout juste un petit peu trop mon
personnage qui est dévorée d'ambition
qui veut devenir adjudant chef qui le
devient qu'il ne reste pas très
longtemps qu'il revient nous n'aurait
jamais dû sortir d'ailleurs est ce que
quand on tourne un film comme ça avec 3
épisode 3 épisodes c'est donc le
tranchant pour des épisodes neigeux doit
totalement différentes qui n'ont rien à
voir oui mais le personnage reste quand
même le même
et est-ce qu'on finit par s'attacher à
ce personnage ou pas ah oui je veux être
a pu le tester à l'enim au ventre et
puis je me suis beaucoup attaché au
personnel des gendarmes
vous avez l'impression que deux films
hors films où vous trouvez plus de
réalisme plus de meubles vous avez
besoin de plus de réalisme vous avez le
gendarme se marie cet afflux qui a
demandé un tournage très long très long
parce qu'on nous avons eu les événements
de mai juin qui nous ont retardés
voilà est le lieu où les deux voulaient
tourner saint tropez tout à saint tropez
et en extérieur tout en extérieur voit
très peu de choses à paris tout ça ça va
les gens qui assistent aux tournages en
extérieur quelle est leur réaction
lorsqu'on pouvait travailler ma légion
de jadis mais comment s'assurer d'abord
il commence à s'ennuyer
parce que c'est long c'est assez
démoralisant beau tourner un film en
commence une scène on attend peut-être
trois heures que cela vienne on attend
quatre heures
on répète 30 soit on tourne bien fois
c'est très démoralisante très déprimant
paie pas pour nous ça fait partie du
métier
oui pour vous le contact avec le public
pendant le travail droit de tourner
oui c'est pas gênant en pas du tout sauf
que le public n'avait évidemment on peut
pas lui demander de rire parce que ces
deux là ne peux pas mais c'est embêtant
c'est ce que c'est ce que je préfère
dans le théâtre parce que les public rit
et là une chose qui est indéniable c'est
que vous êtes vous êtes un acteur
comique est ce que il vous est venu à
l'esprit ce que vous souhaiteriez faire
autre chose que du comic sans parler
d'une possibilité vous est ce que vous
aimez rhône où le brillant qu'ils ont
magnifiquement beaucoup mieux que en
fait mais en plus je sens que ce n'est
pas je sais pas mon travail j'ai préféré
j'ai encore bien des choses à défricher
les comics bien des forêts j'essaie de
faire ce qui arriva à monsieur comme moi
l'embouchure de monsieur jean kahn
devait arriver pour aller d'un point à
celle de monsieur mon général j'aime
beaucoup ces situations je me lève le
matin à cause de mon lycée le point a et
il faut aller au point x ou au point zkb
non le point a et il fallait au point b
eh bien mon personnage se lève il y
avait là bas et qui peut se permettre de
dire qu'il va aller là-bas qui va
arriver à l'heure juste là entre temps
il ay la rue datas leur attendant lui
ont valu de passe trop et ça c'est les
choses de la vie qui peuvent arriver
d'ailleurs est ce que on à l'évidence de
l'audio nous parlions de avec ma femme
des enfants d'union ont permis une chose
grave très grave
et le cap qui va tout le temps le cas il
y en a quatre qui est descendu de sa il
essaie son dû subitement tout le monde
élève tout le monde a sauté dessus
on parlait plus du tout de la chaudière
je me rappelle même plus ce que c'était
on est le cas des cas ne lui valut à
tomber et que va nous casser il
accommode qui est très bon m ce qui vaut
très cher
il ya des choix et il ya quatre ans plus
tard quatre n'y a pas d'excusés mais les
gros mots ce cadre et voilà c'est ça de
bona du quotidien et ses voiles alors un
peu mon comics et ça je crois
[Musique]